auntie baman 2015 great your video games
I'm already looking forward to febri
fifth because XCOM 2 is common this is
the first time I think we've had hands
on with it and cool I played two whole
missions real quick I want to talk about
what you can do on the carrier base ok
this is the new base it's a floating
base yeah as we've seen but you know I
didn't get to see all of it but here's
some here's some good [ __ ] gun
customization right with mods and
everything colors patterns like little
smiley faces on your gun yeah you want
to rename your gun sure do I named my
sniper rifle mr. bangi that's pretty
good and there was a harsh I'll say
character limit okay at this point
because I wanted to name it mr. boom
boom boom too many too many cares what
Solomon yeah so the module had available
come in like two flavors there's a
standard like bigger clip that's obvious
ok then this is like really cool ones
that are like give you a five percent
chance to just insta kill your target oh
wow real low percentage stuff and it's
like five percent chance to not use your
action points for that gun oh that's
real you could just imagine that moment
yeah so you so you're like kind of
forget you haven't you do it yo oh there
we go that's excellent so that's that
can add a nice fun little layer now I
can't really talk about more about the
strategy layer if you want you know for
axis calls it that because we didn't see
much but the enemy is working on a
project and you're working to stop the
project that's it that's the game what
happens when they complete the project I
don't know you probably lose that
happens a lot next comp yeah so on to
the mission like actual election Leah
and yeah it's just more XCOM right but
they've added these nice touches that
make it so awesome first of all sure you
start the mission undetected oh yeah you
have to incite the attack to be revealed
by the enemy oh they don't even know
you're there they don't even know you're
coming I don't know if this is true for
every single mission right there could
be scenarios are different now what this
does though is it as this this level of
strategic thinking where you're not leap
frogging because you're scared of
getting caught out of [ __ ] cover and
dying by one sectoid right that's that's
no longer on your mind on your mind is
setting up elaborate ambushes using the
overwatch because when you're going to
overwatch when you're not revealed it's
basically like once you reveal then
shoot yes so you'll have one guy
activate the shoot and then like your
other four guys on overwatch raining
down there
because in the old games you would
trigger them by getting close to them
but they're waiting for you and they
basically scurried into defensive
positions but you can Shepherd them into
like [ __ ] pincer movement and then
it's like BAM yeah everyone get smoked
and the tiles that will reveal you are
indicated so you're not you're not gonna
accidentally be uh revealed so you set
you can like set up really elaborately
and you can like run and not worry about
like wasting a turn right so yeah it's
really it's really awesome them two
missions we played how tubes right or
you activate something you've grabbed
something in it you have to go extract
it I'm playing enemy within at the
moment and there's a lot of that sort of
like you know collect these things are
like those missions in the original X
camera was like you gotta hit those
buttons are the the thing is gonna
explode you could theoretically get to
that point completely stealth oh wow and
then grab the thing but then what
happens is you'll be revealed and then
you'll have a lotta enemies coming at
you that you didn't like been heard
before so it's advantageous to actually
like initiate combat that's over or you
could just troll or try yeah bookish and
then run there is a new class called the
Ranger class okay and even though all
your squad is revealed he will stay
still oh we can set up little like
single man ambushes with him and he's
the guy that has the sword oh cool did
you use the sword I used to start I
completely with oh really you missed he
missed I did I I came out against one of
those snake dudes yeah and I was like oh
yeah I'll just use a sword like that
trailer and he whiffed sucks how were
the new enemies did you see any problem
there's foot soldiers instead of sex
woods I thought the basic enemy look at
the hierarchies like that the SEC toys
are bigger and badder and then use just
sigh attacks are on a dudes and raise
Dombey so they're like harder there's
these Mac dudes that have like massive
guns that take out cover and then I ran
into this to snake dudes that's all I
it's also fun I'm going
they talk so fun they didn't use their
tongue attack on me thankfully so we had
asked us to this exosuit armor too okay
and this is important for two reasons
don't know some is a shin and power
armor not fall enough yeah well a little
inspiration maybe um and renaming your
weapons of course uh so you get a
wrist-mounted rocket launcher as a bonus
level with that oh so it's like not only
do you have your huge grenade launcher
your huge minigun with your this
particular class you get an extra
concert great now pretend that soldier
goes down okay in a world where I suck
at XCOM which you know I don't know just
kidding uh he dies or she dies I'm gonna
have to carry her body out Oh No in
order to save that key suit oh really I
actually did have one of my dudes die
only one and I wanted to see what happen
if I carried him out mm-hmm still bed
already nothing that yeah I like that so
I get the idea the suit reminds me of
the remember the missile turret things
in the original Tom like that in 94 but
yet carrying out your gear that's great
now there's so much going on that I
could tell I just didn't have time to
look at in the base in the world's in
the strategic glare and that's ok cuz we
only had like two hours with the game I
just wanted to play it that's kind of
what you want from an ex-con to write
because it's like it's kind of rushed
now we know what that game is I know so
the feeling i'm left with is this is
XCOM amped up oh cool bike it's just
bigger better and there's so much to see
and I [ __ ] can't wait until tout like
Isis can't wait that's awesome where we
talked to jig saw him a couple months
ago it sounded like they were they
tested the waters without early XCOM
they kind of like nether may be ready to
get a little bit weird yeah who knows
dude it every fifth is when it comes out
that's so soon let's go soon Christmas
the you know January just you know run
and lose the bunch of weight in the next
calm time boom looking forward to it
thanks dude thanks auntie
you